>> Jesse: THE LEGAL BATTLE
BETWEEN JOHNNY DEPP AND HIS
EX-WIFE ISN'T GOING AWAY ANYTIME
SOON.
AMBER HEARD PLANNING TO APPEAL
THE BLOCK BUSTER VERDICT THAT
FOUND HER LIABLE FOR DEFAMING
DEP.
SEEN HERE LIVING IT UP AND
MINGLING.
REVEALING THE ACTRESS WON'T BE
ABLE TO BONY UP AND IS
COMPLAINING ABOUT THE PROCESS.
>> ARE YOU STUNNED THAT THE
INJURY ESSENTIALLY REJECTED HER
STORY?
>> A NUMBER OF THINGS WERE
ALLOWED IN THIS COURT THAT
SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN ALLOWED.
AND IT CAUSED THE JURY TO BE
CONFUSED.
>> DOES YOUR CLIENT WANT TO
APPEAL?
>> OH, ABSOLUTELY AND SHE HAS
SOME EXCELLENT GROUNDS FOR IT.
>> IS SHE ABLE TO PAY A
$10.4 MILLION JUDGMENT?
>> OH, NO.
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT, JUDGE, WHAT
HAPPENS NOW?
>> Judge Jeanine: OKAY, SO THE
ATTORNEY SAYS SHE'S GOING TO
APPEAL.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT SHE'S GOING TO
APPEAL ABOUT.
THIS ATTORNEY'S TALKING ABOUT
THE FACT THAT THERE WAS EVIDENCE
ADMITTED THAT SHOULDN'T HAVE
BEEN ADMITTED.
LET'S MAKE -- LET'S HOPE SHE
MADE A RECORD FOR APPEAL.
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS SHE'S
COMPLAINING ABOUT IS THE SOCIAL
MEDIA AND HOW THAT INFLUENCED
THE JURY.
WELL, EVERY JURY IS INFORMED
THAT THEY CANNOT CONSIDER NEWS
PAPERS OR WHAT PEOPLE SAY OR
SOCIAL MEDIA IN DETERMINING WHAT
THEIR VERDICT IS GOING TO BE.
I SUSPECT THAT SHE'LL APPEAL.
I DON'T KNOW IF SHE HAS THE
MONEY TO APPEAL.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, IF SHE
DOESN'T HAVE THE MONEY, ANY
FUTURE WAGES SHE GETS WILL BE
GARNISHED.
THERE'S A JUDGMENT AGAINST HER,
IT'S A LEGITIMATE JUDGMENT.
IF THERE IS AN APPEAL, IT
DOESN'T MEAN ANYTHING.
IT DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN IF
SHE WINS, THAT THERE WILL BE A
NEW TRIAL.
I THINK THE EVIDENCE WAS
OVERWHELMING ON THE PART OF
JOHNNY DEPP, THE PLAINTIFF IN
THIS CASE.
SHE WAS OVERWHELMINGLY SEEN AS A
LIAR AND NOT A CREDIBLE WITNESS.
AND, IN THE END, I THINK THAT,
YOU KNOW, IT'S KIND OF
INTERESTING THAT SHE SAYS I
DON'T HAVE MONEY WHEN SHE JUST
BOUGHT A HOUSE.
>> RIGHT.
>> Judge Jeanine: SHE JUST
INSISTED IN LIVING IN ONE OF
THREE PENTHOUSES THAT JOHNNY
DEPP OWNS.
SHE IS A TAKER AND WE'LL SEE
WHAT HAPPENS.
BUT WHAT SHE DID, ONE THING THAT
SHE DID WAS SHE HURT BATTERED
WOMEN.
SHE HURT THE WOMEN COMING
FORWARD.
AND, YOU KNOW, SHE TALKED ABOUT
HOW, YOU KNOW, THAT SHE FELT THE
WRATH OF SOCIETY.
NO.
YOU CREATED A WRATH THAT WASN'T
THERE BECAUSE YOU TRIED TO RIDE
ON THE WINGS OF BATTERED WOMEN.
>> Jesse: RIDE ON THE WINGS OF
BATTERED WOMEN.
JESSICA, WHERE DID THE MONEY GO?
DIDN'T JOHNNY JUST GIVE HER
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
WHEN THEY GOT DIVORCED?
>> Jesse: WELL, PEOPLE WHO LIVE
THESE KIND OF LIFE STYLES CAN
BLOW THROUGH MONEY VERY QUICKLY
AND HAVE A VERY WARPED SENSE OF
WHAT THEIR STANDARD OF LIVING
SHOULD BE.
THIS HAPPENS ALL THE TIME IN
DIVORCE CASES WHERE YOU HEAR
WHOEVER'S ASKING FOR ALIMONY
THEY'RE LIKE OBVIOUSLY I NEED 60
GRAND A MONTH BECAUSE THESE ARE
THE THINGS I DID.
AND IT'S LIKE WELL, YOU DON'T DO
THE JOB THAT DOES THE THING.
SO JUST TO PIGGYBACK ON THE
JUDGE'S POINT ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED TO BATTERED WOMEN I WAS
READING A LOT OF COVERAGE OF
THIS LAST NIGHT FROM LEFT WING
AND RIGHT WING SOURCES AND THIS
WAS A CONCERN FOR EVERY SINGLE
PERSON THAT WAS WRITING ABOUT
THE ISSUE, WHETHER THEY ACTUALLY
BELIEVED AMBER HEARD OR NOT AND
THEY JUST SAID THAT THIS PUT THE
IDEA OF CALLING INTO QUESTION OR
THAT PEOPLE FAKE THESE KINDS OF
THINGS SO BLATANTLY ALL OVER OUR
TELEVISIONS THAT IT'S GOING TO
HAVE A REALLY NEGATIVE EFFECT
LONG TERM ON TRUE SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WHO HAVE A
RIGHT TO TAKE PEOPLE TO COURT
OVER THINGS LIKE THIS.
>> Jesse: DO YOU THINK JOHNNY
WILL GARNISH HER WAGES OR DO YOU
THINK THERE WILL NOT BE ANY
WAGES TO GARNISH?
>> Katie: I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
GARNISHING WILL LOOK LIKE I'M
NOT SURE BUT I WAS LOOKING AT
THE LEAD-UP AND SHE'S LOOKING
WHETHER IT WAS WORTH IT.
THE PUBLISHER WAS TRYING TO GET
HER ON THE ME TOO TRAIN THE PR
POLICY THAT HOLLYWOOD PUT
TOGETHER DURING THE #METOO
MOVEMENT THEY TURNED IT INTO
THIS WHOLE RED CARPET EVENT
EVERYBODY GETTING IN ON IT.
PUSHED HER INTO THE WASHINGTON
POST, THIS ISN'T HER FAULT, BUT
POST-OP EDUCATE, NOW THEY PUT AN
EDITOR'S NOTE ON.
SO THIS WAS A MATTER OF JUMPING
ON THE BANDWAGON FOR ATTENTION
AND DIDN'T END UP GOING VERY
WELL FOR HER.
>> Jesse: GREG?
>> Greg: YOU KNOW, YOU BRING UP
THE WASHINGTON POST AND THAT,
ME, WOULD BE THE IDEAL NEXT STEP
IS DEP SHOULD SUE THE WASHINGTON
POST.
I'M GLAD HE GOT HIS DAY IN COURT
BUT, YOU KNOW, NOT EVERYONE HAS,
YOU KNOW, DEP P'S POCKETS.
I WONDER HOW MANY PIECES WERE
RUN IN THE WASHINGTON POST THAT
WERE JUST AS FALSELY MALICIOUS
BUT NOBODY HAD THE POWER TO
FIGHT THEM BUT HE HAS THE POWER
TO PUT UP HIS DUKES AND YOU HAVE
TO WONDER HOW MUCH INPUT DID THE
WASHINGTON POST HAVE?
IT'S CLEAR SHE DIDN'T WRITE THE
PIECE, ALLEGEDLY SHE DIDN'T
WRITE IT, ACLU CLAIMED SOMEBODY
PUT IT TOGETHER BUT I'M SURE THE
WASHINGTON POST WAS HAPPY TO GET
IT.
MAYBE THEY HELPED HER.
WHY DIDN'T THEY NAME DEP P?
BECAUSE THEY KNEW THEY DIDN'T
HAVE TO.
IT WAS GOING TO BE OBVIOUS.
SO IT SEEMS TO ME THEY'RE
GETTING AWAY WITH IT AND THEY'VE
GOT DEEPER POCKETS THAN AMBER
HEARD SO IT WOULD BE REALLY NICE
TO SEE A NICK SANDMAN TYPE MOVE,
YOU KNOW, AND THEN DEP P CAN
PLAY NICK SAND MAN IN THE NICK
SANDMAN MOVIE.
>> Jesse: ONCE I GET DEP P'S
POCKETS I'M GOING TO SUE THE
WASHINGTON POST.
>> Greg: I'M GOING T